welcome to another episode of AI and I I
am Michael Matias and today we're going
to be exploring the way that artificial
intelligence plays a role in our ability
to trust content at scale and what
strategies and techniques are we
building in our world to be able to
mitigate the potential risks of not
being able to understand the context of
what we are seeing and hearing today I'm
with Paul Melcher who is one of the
world experts in Providence
authentication and generative AI visual
ual Paul has been working at The Cutting
Edge of this industry over the last
several years really ever since the
Inception of generative content much
before it became commonplace Paul has a
deep understanding of the intricacies of
the ecosystem its limitations but the
potential H today we will have an
optimistic yet a um realistic
conversation about the role that
authentication Watermark and Providence
play
in our ability to attach context to
media and this conversation left me
hopeful about the future that we're
going into about the energy and the
effort that is being done to preserve
context in what we're seeing and to
create new layers of trust so thank you
for joining me for this conversation and
let's welcome Paul the evolution of what
we've seen over the last few years like
over the last five years what what's
been happening and and I think that
you're also very bringing a very
optimistic approach right to this space
I I I want to be yes what so maybe maybe
starting with that so where where's the
where where's your optimism coming in
from because you know a lot of what
people are talking about when it comes
to to everything that's happening with
generative VI and digital media from an
authentication perspective it's it's
quite dismal but but you do bring a
certain level of optimism in in the
Solutions in place I I it comes from
from the realization that there's
there's no other option uh than than
being optimistic and try to find
solutions to it so so um I see
generative AI my space is more still
photography so I see generative AI as
being um very close to the same type of
Revolution that painting uh went through
when photography was was discovered uh
at the end of of uh the 19th century and
so what happened there well so so
painters and painting in general was
forced to redefine itself um before it
was everything you did portraits you did
landscape you did even with illustration
uh it was it was covering the news and
everything like that and when
photography came out then suddenly some
limitations were created because now you
had this tool to replicate reality much
better than than any painter could ever
do uh and so it stopped or limited
painting and say basically taking that
part of the the painting process the
portraits or everything that was trying
to mimic reality away from from from
that tool and and saying to the painters
you have to redefine yourself in such a
way which um and that's where my optimis
has come from is it
forced uh it forced them to to become
more creative and the reason we have the
impressionist and the fism and and the
the the Picasso and everybody that that
went further on it's because once they
were forced to to move away from realis
they were forced into more creativity
and forced into something different than
photography was doing and and to me
those are probably at least they my
favorite schools of of painting is is
the impressionist and and and and
everything that followed the cubism and
things like that so photography is at
the same stage today with generative Ai
and the fact that now you have machines
that can replicate photography as as as
as well if not sometimes better than
than what photography does it forces
photographers the ones using light and
lenses to um to create content to
redefine what it means to to be a
photographer and what
photography can do um so so you can't
you cannot anymore do photography like
you did and wake up in the morning and
did like it was like five years ago uh
you have to rethink it and so in the
process uh we're in this extraordinary
moment um of the evolution of
photography
where um yeah it's going to it's going
to change and the opportunities for it
to change are tremendous the same way as
you know if you were a painter when
photography came out you never saw that
that all these possibilities of of
impressionism or everything like were
coming right this it was something that
evolved and so the same ways it's not
clearly defined even in my head what's
photography is going to look like in in
5 years 10 years 20 years from now
traditional photography but it's going
to involed in a way that that is
certainly going to be very very
interesting but it's not like the role
of painters at that point was to move
away from trying to depict reality but
to bring
creativity and art into the into the
painting um H how do you think the
transition for now photographers will be
will it be that photographers are
they're probably not going to try to shy
away from from reality right but what
what is the role then you think that
photography will play as generative AI
takes a larger and larger portion of
media so so yeah uh exactly that they'll
be forced back into reality right so so
we've
taken um we've defined photography the
lens based light light based photography
as as a representation of of reality
because it it it captures uh what's
going on reflection of the light in a
certain way so generative EI is is is
what it is is generated right so it's
not a representation or a capture of a
moment in in time it is completely
creative uh you can you can mimic
something that happened but but it's
it's it's not something you capture so
photography will be pushed back into its
limitation as as a document documentary
Tool uh to continue to to uh to
represent reality or to witness reality
um with that and generative AI um
because of its possibility can will will
take over that creative part of
Photography uh and and you'll be or
artists would be much more empowered or
or allowed to be much more creative
using Genera AI than photography would
would has ever allowed them to be we've
seen that a little bit when people
created stuff with Photoshop but now
because of generate AI it's becoming
much easier and and open to to a wider
audience do we have some did we learn
things about the behavior of the
documenters versus the creators if I
take your analogy of the role
photographers versus those that are
using um I guess video different editing
tools what what did we learn from the
last I guess two decades of using
Photoshop and these types of tools that
we can then that can help give us an
indication of where we're
heading what have we Lear we've learned
a lot of things I think uh what we
learned is is is the endless flexibility
of of photography or or still
photography uh in general uh and it's
it's basically created the groundwork
for what will be done with generator VI
um in in a much
um in a much wider um way
um it's
also it's moving forward I think those
tools will be ironically prob less used
by photographer because they will enter
the realm of generative AI rather than
than traditional photography um because
if you want
to uh alter reality then then there's
nothing better than than generative AI
rather than taking photo and then going
to photoshop and so you almost see that
there's going to be two streams of work
one which is let's try to stick as close
to reality as possible and the other one
is saying as long if we don't if that's
not our mission then there's no reason
to go that route because these tools are
going to be probably yeah and to take
some example takes sports or takes
wedding or takes birthday parties right
so you want you your your niece is
having a birthday party uh you're not
going to generate a text uh prompt to do
that one generate Ai and say oh look
look at what I can create for a birthday
party with well maybe if my phone
battery died
halfway but but you'll take your phone
take a snap a picture it can be good it
can be bad could be a little bit out of
focus although with phones now it's
impossible to do that but what you want
is capture reality right and same if
it's a wedding or or or if you want to
see photos of of the latest soccer game
or football you want to see what
happened you don't want to see
somebody's interpretation uh even an AI
interpretation of what happened because
that's something else right so
photography for that traditional
photography will will refocus into that
that realm and saying okay we are the
tool to continue to do that and us as
human being will not drop photography
because we need that relationship with
reality uh that that photography brings
us the the the thing is that we now live
uh our lives in two two areas we live it
in in real life and we have a digital
life and what allows us to move from
back and forth from each uh in in in all
comfort and and somewhat security is
photography we take our real life in
picture and we move it to our social
media we're moving into our Digital Life
right uh that's how we we can move back
and forth between our two lives
seamlessly uh thanks to photography
mostly thanks to photography video
obviously a little bit of text so for
that purpose traditional photography
will continue to be that tool where
where we can we can exist in in two
Realms at the same time Genera AI will
be that digital only part of our lives
where we can create um whatever we want
from from from our existence um and we
won't be able to take that into our real
life unless if we start printing them
and saying oh look at this but um that's
something else so so that's where they
they all fit in um pretty much
absolutely so you know you've spent a
lot a lot of your time especially in
recent years in um in in this context
right in this real to digital and back
to real
landscape um and you've been at the
Forefront of the of the different
technologies that are being used to to
ask this question to help us navigate
through these
transitions um let's go back to the
basics for a second you know why why is
it important in your in your eyes that
we have this distinction well you know
very fundamentally why you know why is
it worth having groups like those some
of the groups that you're a part of and
the companies that you're that you're
working with why why is this in why is
this an a live ecosystem that that also
should succeed hopefully you mean about
authenticity or yeah well authenticity
And in regards to being able to disting
the real versus the the digitally
created uh it's it's it's a fundamental
part of who we are as human beings that
that we we need to we need to have
reassurance about the the um the reality
of our world that's how we make
decisions uh when we know what's real
what's true and what is not real not
true that's how we can make decision and
that's how we can we can put One Foot In
Front the other every day and and and
and make make sure that when we actually
put that foot on the ground it is
there's a ground there and it's not
going to disappear so so we we build
this Foundation reality or or what we
accept or or as reality is is what we
need as as a reference and so have you
ever had the experience of a going down
the stairs and you're maybe you're
occupied something with your mind and
then you're about to and you're taking a
step and you've actually reached the
bottom but something about your body
you're you almost feel like you you feel
like you're almost in a roller coaster
and something didn't translate well and
it caught you by surprise at you at the
end I as were thinking that I was
thinking back to that feeling of
uncertainty that I'm my mind is
perceiving a certain reality and I'm
confronted by a different one that
that's a very scary Split Second yes uh
and that's that's yes that's a that's a
good example although you should not be
looking at your phone when you're going
down the stairs absolutely that's always
dangerous but yeah absolutely and so and
so with the Advent of generative AI what
is going on because of the the the the
quality of reproduction of generative
where our minds cannot make the
difference between a real photograph and
and a generated image um it's throwing a
lot of confusion um in our in our in our
senses and so we cannot rely anymore on
seeing flaws I know last year or even
sometimes still this year generative AI
will will have maybe many two fingers or
something a little bit blurry that that
will be um will give you hints that that
is not a real image but you know moving
forward that's going to disappear uh
very quickly and the same with video and
and a visual content
so in order for us to be able to
continue to function and and again back
to what I was saying about the fact that
we travel back from a digital life to
real life back and forth using images as
our reference points we need to be able
to make and distinguish the difference
uh the say that if I see an image of an
event that is happening uh across the
world that my only point of reference is
that image and I have to trust it to be
what happened uh so I can make decisions
about my world and my environment um my
visual cues are not enough anymore
because of generated so this is where um
tools like Provence identification uh
c2p and and others are are are extremely
relevant because it allows to make the
difference between both it's
not making any judgment whether one is
more valuable than the other it's just
making the point that you can make the
difference between what is real and what
is generated uh and so we can continue
to do process without those uh you know
stepping back it's it's really
interesting because um
we are if you look at the history of
mankind photography is only about 150
years not even uh but in that short
spend of Life of Photography we have
integrated so much that we make
decisions about our world based on that
photography meaning that if you look at
at individuals when they lived uh in the
19th century 18th century 16th century
didn't know what happened beyond their
Village their front door maybe somebody
would tell them something happened you
know far away but that's all they they
knew about we are
constantly informed and mostly visually
about stuff that's happening across the
the the the planet if not Across the
Universe by the way and we find it
completely normal and actually we find
it so normal that we spend our days
making decisions about our daily life
and we incorporate those information
that information into our daily life to
make General you know decisions about
about everything that we do uh a good
example is the the image of the Pentagon
right there was the image of the
Pentagon explosion yeah which within
seconds caused the stock market to dip
right so you're you can actually see
measurably how fast an an experience
that's happening somewhere else around
the world H potentially in another
continent is causing you to make real
world decisions that are impacting
everybody that is why it's critical to
be able to make the difference is it
this is this this is really happened not
happen and and so you can you can you
can make the right decision based on
that yes absolutely and and I like the
distinction that you made that it's that
it's really not about drawing
conclusions or judging which one is more
valuable than the other it's it's just a
question of how do how do we continue to
navigate between these two worlds in a
context in which our visual cues and
auditory cues are just not not as
powerful anymore yeah and and it also
comes back to you know we we we also
tend to to credit photog traditional
photography lens based photography as an
instrument of Truth and and it's it's
not right since the beginning of of
Photography uh you were were able to to
edit manipulate uh the negatives and
there's there's many many example that I
don't know if you know a lot about the
history of photography but there's
famous uh story about the fairies where
this this uh doctor took pictures of his
backyard and then added fairies and then
people believe that they were he
photographed actually fairies uh in this
thing and that comes all the way back to
beginning of Photography uh as well as
is manipulated this famous photos of of
Lenin and and and political activists
erased uh afterwards because you know
they were not fashioned anyway so
anyways uh it's always been part of
Photography so uh the fact you know it's
a recording of truth but it's not it's
not so much a recording of truth because
it it is it can be altered uh and it's
part of the DNA of Photography we
actually enjoy the fact that we can
alter the image we we've all used
photography and we've all retouched
things or cro things out or retouched
the lighting or things like that because
you know it's you want to look at better
you want to make it to look better so so
it's it's normal uh however what
photography is is is is a a form of of
of witness it's uh the same way as you
would be in a trial and somebody would
explain to you what happened uh in that
Event Photography the same way it's it's
an image that that gives an
interpretation of what happened uh at
that point of time in fact I think
digital media's video audio and images
are now part of maybe 80% of Court
proceedings in litigations right because
they are very effective representations
of here is what happened at a certain
point in reality H we don't have to just
but it's still a a witness point of view
it's not a fact it's just somebody's
interpretation or vision of things
absolutely it's one angle one perception
absolutely and that's that's important
to keep in mind because when you're
dealing with identification of
Providence that's what you're you're
aiming to do so you're not saying that
that image or that video is is true what
you're saying is that that image or that
video came from that person or that
organization uh to you and then you the
recipient the consumer of that content
can then take an intelligent decision
whether you're going to accept that as
being true or not right so same image or
same event uh if once is officially
tagged it says it comes from from a
photographer from the Associated Press
for example and you can see that there's
a good chance that you will see okay I
can I can trust that image M if another
image comes and it's signed by the
department of of of uh of information of
uh of China or Russian or or things like
that you would say uh maybe I might not
trust it as much right so the
authentification process is giving you
the Providence up to you to decide if
you're going to take that as
being a true statement or if it's
something that you're going to be in so
you see that different different
stakeholders and different users will
have different perspectives on on what
providence needs to take place in order
to consider this information as truthful
or as valid absolutely Tru Trust is is
human to humans right we don't trust
machines we trust the people driving the
machines like you don't trust the
airplane you trust the pilot driving
your you don't trust you know the the
car you try you trust the the cab driver
to to to to to not crush the car so um
the same way as you tell me something I
might decide because you've lied to me
many times before m whatever comes out
of your mouth I'm not going to believe
it or the opposite right so the same way
with photography of visual content the
recipient makes a decision based on
their knowledge of the the Providence
whether they can accept that as truth or
not the the the the Prov being always
starting with a human being right or an
organization that is managed by human
being but so that's where you create the
link between the two between the
recipient and and the originator of the
content so that the chain of trust can
be created or can be broken based on
that but you need that information to
travel with with that image or that
video so that you can you can make that
decision with that without that
information all you have is an image or
video and you don't know if it was
generated you don't know if it was
manipulated in some way you don't know
who took it you don't know why they took
it you know things like that and then
that's where that's where it becomes
problematic without without that
information so so you're making a
distinction of of there's it's it's a
two-part system you have the found
foundational infrastructure which is how
do we what do we what do we know about
this media what do we know about the
information the context of the media
where it came from who took it who
edited it Etc and then it's a question
of given this pieces of
information can we trust it does this
fit into our our um our box um thought
model of what what is truthful
information or or trusted sources or
trusted information right absolutely
yeah that's that's the idea behind
behind all this this effort behind
Provence and and ctpa content
authenticity initiatives and and and
related uh efforts uh in in order again
to to preserve
uh our ability to to consume photography
the way we've always done uh traditional
photography or generated photography by
the way right uh but a way where where
we know where it's coming from therefore
we can know what level of trust we can
put into it and and you know and manage
our
information uh right
and so so Providence is not it's not an
extremely New Concept but its
implementation across digital media is
relatively new walk me through a little
bit about what know H how this whole
thing came to be in and and and we'll
get to where we are today as well so the
initial thought was that just
technology is not capable of keeping up
with technology itself meaning that if
you try to create systems that
automatically detect falsehood somebody
will figure out how the system works and
then create new ways to create
falsehoods and it's just like a
continuous Chase one after the other and
all so
uh it was the idea was to to say Well if
you know who took an image or who is is
generated a file gener it could be sound
it could be video it could be uh then
you can understand the the intent behind
it and if you get the intent you know if
there's a you can figure out if there's
an intent to to deceive or to inform or
what's what's the purpose right uh if if
if I know you took a picture of that of
your your nephew's uh birthday for
example and you share it with me I'm
going to know because it's you that you
have no intent to deceive me you just
want to show you're proud of your
nephew's birthday you know so I'm going
like oh he it's that's what happened
right sure uh so so that's important so
and that cannot be defeated by
technology by knowing you know the
provence the source of the Providence or
the person and the intent and so that's
that's the core Foundation of of the
idea behind it uh after that it's it's
all the technology in trying to attach
that information to all the pieces of
media that we consume and the different
formats between video sounds and and
others to make sure that that we have
that information uh to be deciphered
here and so when you actually uncover
the the uh the the growth of this of
this industry um it it had a special
progression I think until now I'm I'm a
little bit surprised every time I look
at the the progress we've made and how
fast this is this is accelerated I
believe in the there was recently the um
con the the meeting in at Stanford right
in December around uh around ctpa
content authenticity initiative and I
believe in in Han fed's closing remarks
he talked about how how how how amazed
he is at the pace of at the pace of
execution that that this has come to
life what are you experiencing it the
same way yes I I'm I'm yes and that's
why maybe I'm optimistic as well so one
thing about the Symposium I we were all
surprised how many people showed up uh
because before that nobody we were never
regrouped into one place and so it was
just this was the first time that was
the first time really uh and CP has been
around for a while right it's been
around for four years uh well the ca the
the content authenticity initiative has
been around for four years c2p for three
I think um so but it's a very short time
for creating a format like that or
trying to to do that and what was
exciting about it is that in the same
room you had the New York Times you had
Microsoft you had you had Google and
then you had also startups uh you know
that that just open up two or three
weeks ago maybe longer than a month or
two so you had but the same Synergy and
the same intent of of trying to get this
solved uh and and this to become a
standard for everybody to use uh widely
with the same level of energy where
you're talking to the New York Times or
or or or smaller companies and that that
was really um that was really uh
heartwarming but uh the pace is yes
absolutely uh there is there's an
urgency right uh there's now more
computer generated or generated of
images out there than there's been real
images created since the beginning of
Photography so in a in the last two
years we've created more images than
there were real images created before
yes so we're already getting flooded by
wow false images um Google search image
search results when you type in things
Google currently does not have a
mechanism to differentiate between real
images and fake images so you could be
typing something like Ukraine war and
the top images that you see in the
results some of them could be generated
by I never happened right because Google
image doesn't have the tool to to to
discriminate you would not you would not
know if it's placed in the website that
looks you know legitimately news or
things like that I think the number is
there's about 40 elections this year
going on worldwide and over a billion
people about to vote so just putting
that in perspective that people are
making those decisions who they're going
to vote for based on like we said before
on on information they receive about the
world that is through photography mainly
that they see online whether it's social
media or or the articles that they read
or things like that then the the
potential for for real serious damage to
our societies is is huge right um if you
cannot make proper decisions you cannot
vote properly if you cannot vote
properly um it's the end of democracies
if it's the end of democracies it could
be the end of our Societies in general
right so so the stakes are are huge it's
really a civilization uh right uh uh
life-changing civilization aspect of it
so so there's
that urgency on the people that that
realize that to implement that and make
that happen because they realize this is
this is now uh this needs to happen now
not you know uh in two two years or five
years or we don't have the time and and
so what's the current state of of of
Affairs where are we at are we ready to
to to enact this solution at Large Scale
um we're talking about 40 elections this
year we're saying you're always saying
generative AI there's more generative AI
content than there is authentic content
from here I imagine that that the Gap
will just widen exponentially fast I
think it was a a europ pole that
estimated that by or experts from the
Euro that that by 2026 more than 90% of
content online will be AI generated
sounds like maybe we're going to reach
that faster probably faster yes um by
the way which is quite astonishing I
have to say when when we started Clarity
a year and a half ago that was that
statistic came a few months after we
started Clarity and we had that and and
that used to be something that I would I
would share when I would meeting was
meeting people and back then people were
not necessarily thinking about you know
the the space of acceleration and time
and time again again the reaction that I
got was no way there's no way that by
2026 90 nine out of 10 reals on Tik Tok
or on Instagram will be AI generated and
now we're sitting here and saying well
it's actually gonna probably going to be
faster yeah and I'm on the camp of
faster no definitely and
that's that's we're talking still images
you know we've seen example of of what
will happen with video with glimpse of
Sora uh from open the eye um
that's coming very soon as well uh where
where make you know you text a video
tools that anybody can generate videos
um that looks like the real thing very
very quickly you know before the end of
this year which is going to accelerate
not just s we have a we have a whole
ecosystem of startups raising huge
amounts of capital in order to
accelerate and and meet the market
demand which is endless because it it
fits into a disruption of every vertical
right so it's coming um so that's where
the emergency come from yeah uh but
where we at you know Google meta um um
some of the biggest companies in the
world open AI actually and stability as
well I've signed on and open AI
currently Delhi 3 uh generates uh what
is called a manifest which is a that
metadata information about the origin of
the file so so you can see uh that it
was generated by by Del 3 Del 3 being
uh used by Bing Microsoft search engine
as well and all the Bing uh tools that
that Microsoft is all the Microsoft
tools that that uh are using the del3
also uh have that m m data information
contained in it as well so it's starting
to spread it's starting to be to be
implemented it's starting to be accepted
it's there's still a lot of of work to
be done there's a lot of of Education to
be done so the first part is getting all
these the social media search engines uh
Publishers to to display and show that
information the second part which going
to take a longer time is the education
of of of the audience and the public out
there saying what is this how does this
work you know what what you know what do
I do with this you know so that when
they counter that information they can
use it you know properly so so
effectively what does this mean so we
have all these all these large companies
that are let's say the content
Distributors right some of them are also
creators but they're also they're also
contributors so they when they join this
Coalition when they sign on to this to
this effort what what what effectively
does that mean so there's two parts is
the creators so the Creator part which
embeds that that manifest information
about who they are and not who they are
but you know what what they created so
that that is inscribed or edited right
because some of them are just
manipulating all the chain of yes and
all the chain in between and then the
Publishers which display that content
whether it's social media whe whether
it's it's it's a news media whether it's
a website or anything like that that can
display that content which contains a
little icon which just says CR for for
Content credentials which you can click
on and see the history of that file the
provence source as well as like you said
if there's been any edits and what kind
of edits have happened uh through the
life of of of the image so that you can
see whether an edit was critical and
changing the information in that file or
whether it's simple uh you know
alteration that didn't change at least
the source the the the core information
of that file and and nothing else so so
that again the consumer at the end can
make an educated decision whether to
trust that that that file or not but but
going back to the distinction that
there's one aspect of okay let's let's
capture the information let's get all
these different parameters and all these
different signals of what the of of what
means for this Media or where it came
from who touched it who seen it which
devices it came from and then there's a
question of can I trust it and the
distinction you made before is that we
there is a difference it's not a
universal agreement on can I trust this
media so how do you envision this sort
of this educational piece now or this
consumer piece of how do we then bring
this information to the to the public to
different stakeholders what what does
that look like so the the most the most
common analogy is is your food labeling
on on when you buy food right so uh on
on boxes of your cereals or whatever you
buy or pasta or something like that you
have a description of of what elements
what kind of of of items were were are
contained in the food
right it's up to you to decide if you're
going to eat it or not right nobody says
it doesn't even say actually if it's
dangerous it which you should but that's
something else it doesn't say if it's
dangerous you know the chemicals they
might put on some of the food of things
but it gives you're liable and you're
able to to do your research to find out
which which elements are dangerous which
elements are good for you and things
like that and you eat what you want um
or what you can afford depending on on
on cases but um so that's the same
process right so the education part is
about explaining what this labeling is
and what it's about it's not about
telling people who to trust or what to
trust because that's an individual
choice we no no one can be in a position
unless it's a fascist country uh or
authoritarian um dictatorship of some
kind to tell you what to trust or not to
trust and saying this is true or not
this is this is remains an individual's
uh prerogative or Choice based on their
moral uh education whatever you know is
is influencing their their decision so
so that's not the role of of that tool
or and I I think and where a lot of a
lot of us think that should not be the
role of any tool um to do that and it
sounds like there are certain agre if we
if we continue with the food labeling
analogy there are certain agreements in
society on which labels are are better
for you and which labels are are not as
trustworthy or not as healthy right and
I'm thinking of high trans fat label I
think there is some agreement that if
it's if there's a high trans fat label
it's probably going to be damaging to my
health that changes all the time I mean
I remember that that you know milk was
good for you milk is not good for you
milk is good for you so you know again
that's and it's kind of about the same
thing maybe with with with um Providence
uh it's it's this it's a dangerous game
to try to set in stone because also our
moral value changes uh as a society what
we accept as as being okay at one time
changes over time and say well that's
not okay anymore uh you know so so
trying to to force upon uh an idea of
what's what's true or not is is is
extremely dangerous in my perspective
not something that that anybody should
have the right to do um education is the
best to me is the best thing and so for
on the consumer and public level I think
that makes a lot of sense if we look at
it now from an Enterprise perspective so
if we think about the other other
stakeholders that are taking in digital
media that are enjoying Providence and
they need to be able to authenticate the
media coming in or to ask the question
of can I trust this media that's
entering now do you think there there
are some Universal I guess signals for
whether you know if we look at from a
security perspective even you know I'm
I'm assuming that there there will be
some
consolidations taking place there yeah
so so and this is very interesting point
that you you rais because we tend to to
talk about Provence and and these
questions of trust and
authenticity only about the news aspect
of things but it is pretty much as
important if not more important in in
our
um Financial life or commercial lives
you know when we decide to buy products
for example so um we live in a time
where no company can do business without
visual content they need to create
photos of their product or Services
videos and on top of that continuously
communicate about their the brand values
you know going whether you're selling
cars shoes or or yoga classes or you
need to
create now comes generative AI whereby
people can make the difference whether
those photos are actually coming from
your company or somebody else is making
uh fake fake copies so you're a Nike and
I don't want to hit on Nike on on
particularly but I'll use that as an
example and you create your your your
your sneakers and you sell the sneakers
you create photos of your product which
are you know disseminated through
e-commerce stores and like that anybody
today actually can generate a new pair
of sneakers actually if you look and
type Nike you know on online there's a
lot of of fake ones that were generated
by by AI um and then
somebody could use that and say you know
you can buy those and then you enter
your credit card you buy it you never
get anything right because it never it
never ships that's detrimental I mean OB
see for the consumer it's a temp for
Nike also because people say oh Nike I
can't trust anything absolutely so Nike
Nike needs to create a ground truth of
their product images um so that there's
a reference library where people can
come back and say is that image the real
image is is that generated or created by
Nike in the case of of prod is like that
that's fundamental for the existence of
Nik but that's only a sub part of it
right so Provence
c2p but you know talking about trust in
this way it can be automated in so much
that you find or discover or Google
image search discover or or index an
image of a Nike shoe you could have via
API or other systems a link back to the
Nike database of images the ground truth
image and checking whether that image is
actually from Nike or not if there's a
match yes if there's no match suspicious
you know and and Google image search
could flag that and saying careful this
is not you know um verified by Nike um
so that yes but again it takes for the
consumer to trust Nike as as a brand to
want to buy that but we can go for it
further the second part which is which
is extremely also important and you you
touched upon it when you're talking
about the uh the Pentagon photographs U
or fake photographs is public companies
like Nike or Coca-Cola or others so so
they communicate about about their
Executives um doing different things
their coo traveling or making speeches
or doing things so now it becomes easy
to take one of these photos and
manipulate it with using generator or
create a new one of the CEO of Nike and
maybe putting him in a in a very
problematic uh surrounding like around
around naked boys or something like
young boys and publish that on social
media it's a public company it would
take minutes before the value of the
company would start dipping extremely
fast because it's like oh suddenly you
know this is this is wrong right um and
then even Nike came back and said well
this is a fake photo everybody would say
of course Nike is going to say aake
photo it's their CEO they're I'm going
to say oh yes that's what he does in his
SP time right so there too it is
extremely important for Nike to be able
to control uh and manage what images of
of them circulate and being able to to
have tools for people to differentiate
whether this is a real marketing
communication photo video or or or other
or if if if it doesn't contain that
stamp of of authenticity from Nike then
there's a good chance somebody else is
trying to to manipulate people's opinion
so so yes and and how how aware do you
feel is the market today from from the
company's perspectives the large
platforms the Nikes of the world how how
active and vibrant is the conversation
around the urgency for the solution and
the willingness to adopt it do you see
today maybe in comparison to a few years
ago but also in comparison to what you
would expect yourself as somebody who's
thinking about how do we actually re
strive towards a better infrastructure
for us it's it's active in the in the
technical World um the tech companies
are are the first ones to be to
realizing that that it's it's it's a
necessity and and the urgency of it like
Google for example or others of meta uh
I've seen that um it's it's also active
in the news space where Publishers and
and creators of news realize that is is
essential for them to continue their
business they they won't be able to
continue if people don't trust them
anymore or or there's no differenti
between what they produce and and what
comes out of of generative AI so they
need you know that that that that part
it is not
yet uh really seen in the corporate
world or the brand side that we were
just talking about it's starting some
companies are are peeking their ears out
and or heads out and say oh you know
maybe this affects us too in some ways
but it's it's still very much
um very much very quiet in in in that
space it's also a little bit still the
Cal before the storm right I think we we
we're yet to see some really you know
Monumental earthquakes that right so
absolutely what you need is one event
that will trigger everybody's reactions
and say oh oh we need to do something
you know like the Nike example I gave
you hopefully that happen but something
like that where all the other companies
are say oh you know we need to do
something before it happens to us so yes
probably that's that's the scenario but
you know one thing to keep in mind is
that and that's that's a problem uh or
or or or something that needs to be
solved is that there's no Financial for
for Nike or on the commercial side
there's a financial uh value to doing
something like that but when you're
dealing in a new space there's a moral
obligation but there's no Financial
value but by that I
mean if tomorrow the New York Times
turns on this ability to show you on
images the Providence of the images they
they they become uh c2p or content
credential uh
compliant they will not be able to
charge you more money because of that
right why not because consumers or
people reading the New York Times and
say why am I paying more you know to
have the certification that's something
that you know know I I should have when
I buy the New York
Times the back end it's going to cost
money for for the New York Times to
implement that right why why you need
you need to you know develop the the the
um the applications that going to
support that that kind of uh display of
of information uh in in the back end um
and
so that's where the biggest resistance
comes from and saying it's going to cost
money to implement it's not going to
bring us more Revenue it's not going to
bring the New York Times more readers or
Washington Post or or Fox News whatever
uh however it's going to cost us money
to implement when you look at and this
conversation I have almost daily with
with newswires AP or reuter or or or or
gy images um they spend a lot of time
and money you know having photographers
shoot the news and and get that um
disseminated and sold to to Publications
worldwide this the same thing is like
it's going to cost us money to implement
that and and add that to our workflow
but we won't be able to sell those
pictures for more money to these
Publications uh because they're not
going to say well you know it's it's not
worth it um so there is
both a moral understanding that this
needs to to happen but there's a
commercial barrier and saying well it's
going to cost money and and there's no
immediate uh
monetary uh reward for that and and the
um the return on investment is is moral
for the moment and not and not
commercial and that's that's the barri
is there a way to turn that around is
there on is there o are there
opportunities to
monetize
authenticity and the cont content
credentials and the
transparency eventually I think so over
time because I and I'm maybe being
optimistic about it or or this is an
optimistic table um that consumers will
will will want to be able to trust the
the the source of information and go out
and
seek that label the same way as as if
you had a a box of cereal today which
had no food label uh on it you would
probably not buy it because like it's
suspicious uh and and I'm not going to
eat something I don't know what's in
there although I don't know you know
most cereal is probably not good for you
anyways but uh um the same way as as you
go and and look for places where you can
get your news where you have this this
content label so you can have and make
the right decision saying well I trust
these guys and Things So eventually
people will will be willing to pay an
extra or or subscription or something
like that because they realize the value
into having uh uh that that that kind of
of certified news type of thing but in
your perspective it's there's there is a
question mark at the end of the
at the end of the optimistic expectation
you're not sure when that'll happen yes
and no because the the other force in in
play is legislation right so uh in
Europe you see it in in the European
Union they're they're they're passing
laws quickly where uh they're demanding
that at least a generative AI content be
identifiable by everyone right so that
maybe not the newed pictures but if you
can identify one group of images then
you can identify the other right so if
all images generated by AI has some kind
of of indentification that you can
Define then you realize if there's no
identification then then it must be a
real image right so so already this this
splits in in into so uh those laws are
being put into the books of the European
Union there's a good chance that the
United States actually there's been an
executive order from from the president
uh Biden about the
the federal agencies being required to
identify when they're using generated
content whether it's photos or or text
or or audio or videos uh clearly
identify it so that uh the relationship
with with us the citizens of of United
States if and when they're using it we
can clearly see that they've been using
that again there's
no it's not a bad thing to use
generative AI the idea is not to block
for people from doing it but to allow
people to make the difference so so it's
already you know it's it's an executive
order right now it it should you know my
opinion a lot of our people opinion
should be turned into a law we know the
politics in this country can take some
time to to uh to be applied but but
that's that's that's what's going to
happen before the commercial value
happens it's going to be forced upon um
a lot of of these places to to to
implement it by legislation
because there's the elections coming
this year and more after that right and
so the politics behind there realize oh
this might be good for me but that's
also could be mad for me as well so so
even the political class realize that
this is not something they can just let
happen and not do anything about right
now is is the ctpa and Providence is
that is that a silver bullet solution is
that know is that the what solution that
that works always or are there
limitations to the process there's no
there's no civil bullet so so no it's
not uh so c2p or content credentials is
metadata so it's data that's associated
to fils and that traditionally can be
erased or separated from this file and
once that's separated then it's it's
gone uh so so it has its so the media is
effectively it links to some manifest
that's remote and you can erase that
link you could you can severe that link
yes sever that link so so no it's not
it's not perfect so once that done
obviously then you lose all the
information and it's not uh it's not
secure so this there others uh or
there's technologies that can work in
conjunction with that or other type of
technology that that are stronger
depending on on the use case so so
that's that's
one
possibility uh there's ways to reinforce
what they call selft binding um of the m
to the file with using watermarks for
example invisible watermarks that that
can be read and and reunite the data
with the metad data with the file um
like imag right like a company like imag
does that uh yes uh and then there's
there's still the technology side which
allows to to to to be more profound in
the sense that it can reach or discover
alterations of files in a technical way
even if if it's always a cat and mouse
uh issue it's it's it's still efficient
in the sense that it will find a lot of
of of lot of of
um of places where where the metadata is
not strong enough or the the uh the
watermarking is not survived so a
combination of the three uh even with
other more uh other um Solutions um can
work but there's no civil bullet so so
the three the three that you're pointing
out to is the they the the Manifest work
itself can we let's let's make sure that
we Trace the the alterations from the
creation to the
distribution soft binding watermarks of
let's make sure that we keep some some
evidence of what this media is even if
it's trying to be manipulated and we can
trace it back to some manifest right and
then there's the question of can we run
some Downstream analysis on the media so
that even even without the context of
the of the metadata and the Manifest we
can still identify potential alteration
that were not recorded in in the other
solution which is not bulletproof
absolutely
so mer can be can be erased or or
separated Watermark can can fail
sometimes depending on on the
alterations of the fil absolutely uh and
so and the technology there can come in
and see but there's we were talking
about this professor in in um in
Stanford uh that you know very well and
you're gonna help Dan Bon yeah yeah and
so working on a lot of technical cult
Technical Solutions in discovering deep
fakes and and fake content based on on
on on a variety of of solutions uh as
well and so you know we're
talking previously the fact that I I
forget the number this 10 billion
generative AI images circulating in the
world right now with no metadata no
watermarks of any kind so all those for
example the only way to discover them
would be to use a solution Tech
technical solution to to be able to
trace it detection um and and even if
c2p is is is a standard of of all places
and and Watermark it will never be
everywhere um and so this still needs to
to to complement everything and then um
there's others you know this works for
for visual content so videos and photos
you have also sound obviously and then
text uh whereby these elements don't
don't work anymore or as well as with
visual content and you need to find
other Solutions and and so what happens
with audio because we've talked a lot
about about the visuals and pixels and
is audio working the same way from a
Providence perspective the the intent
behind it is the same I'm so I'm not
expert in audio so so that's that's I I
can't go very much in details with that
but but the the idea behind it is is is
the same as far as the c2p approach is
right
uh where is that going to work as well
as is that with visual content that's
the question
uh yeah we'll see but I can't say more
about that because I'm not an expert in
audio files and and the way they work so
absolutely and so you know if you if you
look down the line where you know where
do you think we'll be let's say a year
from now you know paint me you know your
your your picture of of the world of of
where you know from let's say from a
consumer perspective from a consumer
perspective yeah uh a year from now yeah
um boy this this uh I hate predictions
because this this moves so fast much
faster than than than well so that
whatever prediction you make it'll be
faster than that yeah pretty much for
one thing I mean we'll we'll see texture
videos uh generated AI very Advanced
probably still
recognizable because of flaws here and
there in some places but but very coming
very close
uh especially on longer formats if if
it's you know the smaller formats the 10
seconds or or less I think that that's
going to be surprisingly efficient um uh
photos we won't be able to make the
difference with our eyes with any kind
of generative a or or not uh that will
be already gone into reps um and then
sound I mean I just from what I see
sound is already way ahead of of
everything where we can replicate voices
and and music is is already you know in
in that in that space um and then text
obviously which is also very much U
Advanced um on the provent size I you
know it's it's more hopeful I I think
we'll
start it's moving rather quickly I think
we'll see Publications maybe major
publication adopt the the c2p or or cont
Provence and by the end of the summer
and and starting to spread slowly mostly
obviously in in Western East Western
European uh spaces in North American uh
publication and when you say adopt
they'll it means that they'll start to
showcase the content credentials you'll
be able to see that uh you know where
I'm very optimistic is is Sony Canon
Leica um all the big camera camera
manufacturers are implementing that in
inside the camera so that information
will be captured at the moment of of
capture of the image so the new
generation of cameras will already
include that so so
allowing to start from the beginning and
and having that information to be to
travel from from things so that's that's
that's going to help uh enormously uh
the uh the progress of of of that
standard um and I think you know after
Google and others uh obviously other
companies will will start adopting it
because it's it's G to just know and
looking forward probably to to places
like the European Union to to start
asking for the implementation of it uh
and offering subventions to to uh or
grants to Publications or or places
because that's more the way to do it and
that would skip the commercial barrier
we were talking about before in helping
companies and and Publishers implemented
via VIA subvention um so a better I
think when going to be a better place uh
in a year from now as far as as
Providence information and authenticity
is concerned definitely a better place
uh but we will not be there as far as oh
everything's good we can just relax and
and enjoy everything uh there'll still
be more challenges and and and and
probably things that I haven't thought
about yet that will surprise us again
and and obviously a lot of the work that
we that we talked about today is being
is is is more from coming from
foundations and and and open source and
non nonprofits but there's an but there
is an a private ecosystem that it
thrives within so we we did go back and
forth into the question of the
commercial applications and where and
and where is going to be the financial
incentives and and I think we're we're
all aligned that that we want to
introduce Financial incentives because
it accelerates the adoption of these
Technologies right how do you see the
big opportunities here from from from
commercial aspects let's say for
startups in the in this context so what
what are the areas in which startups can
really Thrive over the next few years
when it comes to this question of
content
authenticity um there's there's two
immediate that come to mind first like
we were talking e-commerce or or or any
type that's that's one very clear um
aspect where where all companies will
need a way to to to protect their
content uh and clearly make the
differentiation between between what is
real and what is Ed but uh also in the
scientific world right and when I'm
talking about scientific think about um
the the pharmaceutical world for example
which which spends a lot of huge amount
of money in research and they they
transfer information via photos videos
to to others for certifications for
verifications for you know numerous
reasons um the potential for for for Bad
actors to come in there and do some
damage
is is huge it's bigger almost than than
messing around with elections I think
because that that could affect you know
medications and things like that and and
those businesses like like a
pharmaceutical companies International
can be seriously damaged by by U by fake
information or or
manipulated um
information you know they they used a
lot all their scientific um presentation
you know sell things are are photographs
right or or representation so you you
add the possibility to create deep fakes
with those and and manipulate them and
and you can the damage could be really
big so these companies having such big
stake in it well the same way as they
are protected against any entry into
their system and and and I think you
cyber security is your background so you
know more about that um the same way
they need to to create those same
barriers around their visual content uh
and and their scientific content to make
sure that that they have the ground
truth in one place and as well as when
this stuff travels it's even when it
does get manipulated it could be
identified immediately so that it
stopped there before it can make real
damage so uh that's definitely and then
obviously military uh I can't imagine
the headaches of military across the
world that depends so much on satellite
imagery and and and other type of of
drones and and you know video footage
and and as well as Ste footage uh if you
can hack those and show them something
different than what is really
happening right absolutely so they need
also a way to um to figure out you know
what what that what they're getting is
is the real information and that's
something that that is manipulated
absolutely you know Paul to end on a on
a light note um you know I'm I I remain
very very optimistic not just on on the
ability for us to to implement these
Solutions commercially and to get them
ultimately to both to Consumers and and
I do have a certain level of of Hope and
expectation that we will write that that
we will um re you know sort of come back
to the our senses that you know the the
value of trust and Truth does matter on
a very F fundamental level especially
and and I think it'll depend a lot on
the quality of the products that are
coming from the market how easy they are
to use and how integrated they are into
our ecosystem but what I'm really
excited about is that you know I grew up
with with a laptop and I grew up with
the phone in my hand and I grew up into
social media and I grew up constantly
hearing about misinformation and fake
information and and that it's almost
like an an unbeatable Challenge and it's
impossible to fight in in a in a
coherent way and what it feels to me
over the last two three years is almost
that there is this now this Collective
effort to rebuild a new infrastructure
which never existed before and there
were never the market incentives to
build and this new infrastructure can
potentially lay the foundations for a
world in which a lot of the misin the
traditional misinformation we've had
will hopefully be debunked through this
new infrastructure and so I do EnV
visional World in a few years in which
we will create new standards for the
information we see online both in real
time and offline attributed with
Provence with detection tools with
watermarks and and that will create a
new expectation of of what information
do we trust and not trust and I think
that may also go back and and I think we
may end up in a in a much better world
and a much better internet environment
than the one we were in even 10 years
ago before we had generative Ai and so
I'm I'm kind of hopeful that if we if we
look at the trend we we have a strong
dip now and that's the urgency that
you're talking about the 40 elections
the three billion people voting and but
I think that hopefully we'll we'll end
up in a much higher altitude and I I
you're more optimis mytic than I am but
yeah I really hope so yes thank you so
much for being here thank you thank you